all of the phase changes we've been
doing so far have been under constant
pressure conditions and in particular
with the problems that I've been doing
with water phase changes in the last
couple of videos it was that it was at
atmospheric pressure at least at sea
level atmospheric pressure or at one
atmosphere so it was done will I'll
explain this diagram in a second but we
all know that in the universe pressure
isn't always constant and it definitely
isn't always constant at one atmosphere
one atmosphere was defined is the
pressure at sea level on earth obviously
pressure will vary wildly if you go to
smaller planets or larger planets or
atmospheres would have thicker
atmospheres or if we're just doing
different types of applications dealing
with gases and liquids and solids so
what I've drawn here is a phase diagram
let me write that down phase diagram
phase diagram and there are many forms
of phase diagrams these are this is the
most common form that you might see in
your chemistry class or on some
standardized test and what it captures
is is the different states of matter and
when they transition according to
temperature and pressure and this is a
phase diagram for water so just to
understand what's going on here is that
on this axis I have pressure pressure on
the x axis I have temperature and at any
given point this diagram will tell you
whether you're dealing with a solid so
solid will be here solid a liquid will
be here liquid or gas or gas for example
if I told you that I was at oh I don't
know if I was at 0 degrees let's say D 0
degrees is right there if I'm at 0
degrees Celsius and 1 atmosphere where
am I so 0 degrees 1 atmosphere am i
right at that point right there so I'm
at a boundary point between solids and
liquids at 1 atmosphere of pressure
right this is when we're at one
atmosphere of pressure so this coincides
with our traditional notion of when ice
freezes or when it melts at 0 degrees if
we made the pressure higher if
you made the pressure higher what
happens well then ice starts melting at
a lower temperature right so this is
pressure going up so pressure going up
would say I don't know what this is this
is maybe 10 atmospheres 10 times its
atmospheric pressure at sea level then
all of a sudden the temperature at which
solid turns into liquid right this
transition is solid to liquid the
temperature would just that that happens
will go down
likewise if we lower the pressure if we
go to Denver you know it's a mile high
pressure is lower because we have less
of the atmosphere above us then all of a
sudden the boiling point I'm sorry the
freezing point increases so the freezing
point will be something above one degree
and this isn't drawn complete to the
scale but the idea is your ice would
actually freeze a little bit faster and
would freeze at a higher temperature in
Denver than it would is at the at the
bottom of the Dead Sea or the at the
Death Valley it's some very low below
sea level point on the planet now this
transition is the transition between
well between anything and gas and we're
very familiar this is one atmosphere and
remember this is water we're dealing
with this is the diagram for water so at
one atmosphere this is kind of the stuff
that we're used to seeing let me draw a
line here so at 1 atmosphere zero
degrees zero degrees is where is where
solid or ice turns into liquid water and
then we go up here so we keep going the
higher higher higher temperature and
then here this would be since we're at
one atmosphere this is 100 degrees 100
degrees Celsius right there and that's
the point it at one atmosphere pressure
where liquid turns into gas or water
vaporizes or the liquid boils all of
those are acceptable ways to think about
that but what happens when we go to low
pressure once again let's take our
little trip to Denver right so that's
Denver right there Denver it's not that
drastic I'm just doing that for
education purposes or even better let's
say Mount Everest Mount Everest Mount
Everest very low pressure there
then our freezing point we already said
that goes up when you lower the pressure
and your boiling point goes down so it's
much easier to boil to boil something on
the top of Mount Everest than it is to
boil it at the bottom or at the lowest
point in Death Valley or the Dead Sea
and the reason the way the intuition
behind that is if I have a if I have a
liquid if I have a liquid a bunch of
molecules in liquid form and they're
touching each other but they have enough
kinetic energy to move past each other
so they're moving there they're flowing
past each other they're kind of rubbing
up against each other one of the reasons
why they don't just evaporate why you
know this guy doesn't just jump up there
is that there's air above him there's
air pressure and air pressure we've
learned about this when we did PV NRT
that's a bunch of gas molecules and the
pressure they're creating is essentially
caused by their temperature and their
kinetic energy and they they sit there
and they bounce and they they
essentially keep these heavier molecules
from going up they keep them from from
from essentially separating from each
other and turning into a gas so the more
pressure you have the harder it is for
these guys to escape on the other hand
if you have very very if we're a vacuum
if we're doing this on the surface of
the moon and there's none of these guys
there then just a little slight bump
even though this guy is still a little
bit attracted to over here they're still
attracted to each other but just a
little bit of bump since there's no
pressure up here for on the floor for
some moon might allow this guy to to
escape and and and go straight to a gas
so when you lower the pressure it's just
that much easier to go from liquid to
gas or even from solid to gas and you
might say Sal that's a bizarre concept
solid to guess and it turns out if you
get to low enough pressures here I mean
let's say this is this is actually
there's probably not stuff here this is
probably close to a vacuum right here
you could go from I so if you took ice
and you were on the moon and you are at
the right temperature this is you know
maybe some negative negative degree
Celsius temperature I don't know what
the exact temperature is your ice on the
moon would go directly from ice to a gas
because there's no there's this huge
vacuum here so these molecules will say
hey
so all the space to fill and if they
just get bumped a little bit they're
just going to escape and turn into a gas
and you might say Oh Sal that's that's a
strange phenomenon it only exists on the
moon and because to to rebut that
comment I've drawn the phase diagram for
carbon dioxide carbon dioxide what we
are you it's all around you you're
exhaling it as we speak your plants in
the room or hopefully inhaling it but
carbon dioxide at one atmosphere has a
very different behavior than water this
is carbon dioxide at one atom so and
just so you know the this scale is
definitely not drawn to scale the
difference between one atmosphere and
five atmospheres is not the same between
five atmospheres and seventy-three
likewise this is not drawn to scale here
this is a much larger distance than this
so if I had to really draw it to scale
out to stretch this chart out or do a
logarithmic chart or something but
anyway I was talking about carbon
dioxide so this is carbon dioxide solid
and this is gas and this is liquid
carbon dioxide so at one atmosphere so
if it didn't like you know let's say you
live at sea level I looked your in your
New Orleans I guess it's a little bit
below sea level that's where I grew up
if you were able to get your fridge down
to minus eighty degrees Celsius the
carbon dioxide would actually freeze and
you're actually not too unfamiliar with
that all right at least you haven't been
if you've gone to some I don't know if
they still use it to make for smoke
machines or for visual effects on stage
but this is dry ice
dry ice it's frozen carbon dioxide and
then as soon as you get above if you're
at if you're at a kind of a sea level
atmospheric pressure as soon as you get
above this minus seventy eight and a
half degrees Celsius it sublimates to
gas so that process where you go
straight from a solid to a gas is
sublimation sublimation and that's why I
dry ice when you see it there's you
don't see liquid dry ice or I mean you
don't see it at standard pressures I've
never seen liquid carbon dioxide in or
in fact order to get liquid carbon
dioxide you have to get above five
atmosphere so you have to get above five
times the sea level pressure on earth
and you're really not going to see that
in natural conditions on earth you might
see that on
Saturn where you have tremendous
pressures because of the gravity and all
of the atmosphere above you so this is a
kind of thing liquid carbon dioxide you
might see I don't know if Jupiter
actually has carbon but you'll probably
see it on other huge massive planets
that are gas giants but on earth this
process is just called sublimation it's
just a neat word or it's sublimating
it's going straight from solid to gas
and it's something you've seen with dry
ice now there's a couple of other
interesting points here and you've
probably already noticing them and this
right here is called the triple point
because right here at this well in the
case of carbon dioxide at five
atmospheres and minus 56 degrees Celsius
the carbon dioxide is in a state of
equilibrium between the ice the liquid
and the gas it's a little bit of all of
the three and if you just nudge it in
one direction or another by nudging the
pressure the temperature it'll go in
that direction similarly waters triple
point triple point is right here it's at
a much lower pressure than we're used to
dealing with this is 611 or 0.6 11 kilo
Pascal's or just 611 Pascal's which is
you know not five thousandths of an
atmosphere so if you go down to five
thousandths of an atmosphere and you go
a little bit above a little bit above
zero degrees Celsius you're at the
triple point of water where water can
take on any of these states where it's
if you just nudge in one direction or
another now the other interesting point
on these charts is up here this is the
critical point sounds very important
critical point and that's the point at
which if you increase the temperature
beyond that or the pressure beyond that
you're dealing with a supercritical
fluid supercritical fluid sounds very
exciting so above here you have a
supercritical fluid so very high
temperature very high pressure so it's
so high temperature that it wants to be
a gas but you're putting so much
pressure on it that it wants to be a
fluid so it's a little bit of both and
actually in the case of water
supercritical water is actually used as
a solvent because you can imagine it's
it's kind of like liquid water and that
things can dissolve in it but it's so
high temperature and it can it can
diffuse into solids that it's really
good at just you know getting whatever
you want
out of whatever you're trying to clean
or somehow so get into or I guess get
get salt you know put into the water so
this is supercritical fluid and so it's
a fun thing to think about but anyway I
just wanted to expose you to these two
these phase diagrams actually let me
just let me just everything I've done so
far was that a constant pressure and I
change the temperature but you can also
read them the other way if I'm at a
hundred degrees and I go from let's say
I'm at 110 degrees or we're at sea level
is comfortably in the gaseous phase for
so this is 110 degrees for for water its
water vapor but if I were to increase
the pressure and keep increasing the
pressure maybe I you know dig a hole or
something or going to the into the ocean
then it's going to it's going to
condense into water or it's going to
condense into a liquid if I did that
experiment here well that's probably
let's say I did the experiment I did
experiment here when I increase the
pressure I'm going to reverse sublimate
and I think I wrote down a word for what
that is let me see if I wrote it down
someplace oh no I didn't I didn't write
it down but essentially it's it's
something like condensed but my brain
did though the word is is escaping me at
the second it's something on the word of
condensing or falling together anyway I
forget the word but it'll go straight
from a gas to a solid so these are
pretty neat diagrams actually tell a lot
about different substances and then tell
you what happens when the pressure or
the temperature changes